وقصتنا اليوم في العراق عن الساعه نعم
الصوفيه هذه المهنه التي تقاوم الاندثار
يمتهنها محترفوها ويذكرون انهم توارثوها
عن ابائهم واجدادهم انتشرت هذه المهنه منذ
زمن طويل في المحافظات التي تشتهر بزراعه
النخيل مثل الدياله والحله وبغداد وكربلاء
بينما تنداثر في المحافظات الجنوبيه تحولت
المهنه الى نوع من التراث الشعبي
افسع في النخيل يزين
زواج التي تعكس جزءا من التراث وكذلك
المطاعم والاماكن العامه في سوق
المرحلانيه واحد اقدم اسواق مدينه
الكاظميه في بغداد يحفظ محترف الصناعه
الصحفيه قصا كثيرا عن هذه الصناعه وكيف
يتم تصنيع الاثاث من سعف النخيل سنستمع
لها في هذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
سوق الملحاني في منطقه الكاظميه الى جانب
الكرخ من العاصمه بغداد
هنا تحديدا يوجد صانع الاثاث الماخوذ عن
سعف النخيل او الجريد كما يسمى محليا ابو
عباس واحد ممن احترفوا هذه المهنه
ورثها عن ابائه واجداده في محافظه ديالى
وامتهنها حتى يومنا هذا
هذا الشيء قديم مش جمع يعني اني جيت بهذا
السوق بسنه الالفين وهذا السوق موجود قبلي
يعني من زمن ابويا
يعمل بالهويدر هي موجوده هاي الشغله عشان
ما تلقى عصريه وبعدين قام يجيبون جاهز من
الناصريه بالنسبه للقصر اما بالنسبه انه
نشتغل بالسعف هي هاي شغلتنا من زمان
موجودين هنايا واللي قبلي اكو ناس بطله
تركت المصلحه واكو ناس بعدت يستخدم ابو
عباس سعف النخيل رطبا قبل تجفيفه وبعد
ثقبه باداه
بالسمبا ثم يدخل سعفا جففه وقطعه باشكال
منتظمه في هذه الثقوب صانعا بذلك كراسي
وطاولات واقفاصا واسره من جريد النخيل
اختصاص يشتغلون بالسعر
واكو ناس اختصاص ياخذون ويجيبون
يقشرون من الورق وبعدين يجيبوا لنا السقف
الاخضر اللي هو يتثاقب قابل للتثقيب يعني
شغلنا كله يدوي يعني من الثقب السعف
بالسمبا يدوي
لم تتدخل المكائن في هذه الصناعه وبقيت
المهنه خاضعه للجهد اليدوي باستخدام معدات
بسيطه مثل منشار الخشب والدقه والساطور
والسمبا وبالرغم من انحسار الاقبال على
هذا السوق لكن هنالك طلبا كبيرا على هذا
النوع من الاثاث لتجهيز الاماكن الترفيهيه
التي تعنى بالموروث الشعبي العراقي في
اطلالتها زينب المشاط صباح العربيه بغداد
تبقى معنا من بغداد مراسله صباح العربيه
زينب المشاق زينب اهلا بك ويسلموا عليها
التقرير الجميل يعني نشوف
معاك اكثر عن الصناعات السحريه
بدنا تسالنا سؤال زينب
سمعتينا زينب
صباح الخير يلا الحسين
طيب انا صراحه اتفضلي جاوبي يلا اوكي
الجريد هي من النخل لانه احنا عم نحكي عن
سعف النخل ولكن الجريد هو من اسفل النخل
الجزر الجذع يعني
[موسيقى]
طيب أخذتي اول معلومه
متواجد بشارع الخواصين بسوق المالحاني في
منطقه الكاظميه
هنانه تحديدا يتم صناعه الاثاث من جريد
النخيل والجريد هو جزء من سعف النخيل بعد
اقتلاع الجزء المتبقي بعد اقتلاع الخوص او
اوراق الساعه في يعني
طبعا هذه المهنه اشتهرت قلنا في الاماكن
اللي يكثر فيها زراعه النخيل في العراق
مثل محافظه ديالى ومحافظه كربلاء وغيرها
من المحافظات ولكن عمر هذه المهنه غير
واضح لحد الان اغلب اللي يمتهنون هذه
المهنه تقريبا صار لهم خمس عقود يمتهنون
هذه المهنه ويقولون انهم توارثوها عن
ابائهم وابائهم توارثوها عن اجدادهم طبعا
معي اليوم احد الخواصين اللي احترف هذه
المهنه اللي هو العمه ابو عباس واللي
تقريبا صار له خمسين سنه بهذه المهنه هذه
المهنه سميت بمهنه بالمهنه الصيفيه طبعا
هي تنحصر بالشتاء وتشتهر بالصيف لكن ليش
تنحصر بالشتاء وتشتهر بالصيف خلينا نعرف
عن ابو عباس صباح الخير اهلا وسهلا مرحبا
نكرروا سؤالنا ليش تشتهر هذه المهنه صيفا
وتنحصر شتاء بالصيف عليها اقبال اكثر من
الشتاء سابقا يعني بعصر ابويا وجدي كان
دائما يشتغلون السرير مالت النوم يعني
تنامون برا ماكو كهرباء بالريف مثل ما
يقول مفتوحه وبعدين
الناس قامت
ومبرده وكذا راح السرير وبعدين التجانا
الى الحاضر اشتغل الكراسي والقنافات وقفص
البلبل وغيره وحتى التخومه مالت الكراسي
طبعا اكثر من شكل يعني اكو عادي واكو مثل
ما يقول افضل من عنده وافضل وافضل يعني
حسب الطلب مالنا نشتغل طبعا هذه المهنه
تسمى بمهنه ابو السراير لانه اهلنا قبل
يعني في العراق بسبب انه ما كان اكو
كهرباء وكانت الحياه جدا بسيطه ودرجه
الحراره عاليه جدا بالصيف فكانوا يعني
يقومون برشي اسرع عصرا وبعدين طبعا يضعون
الاسره على اسطح المنازل رشيناها عصرا
وبعدين بالليل ينامون يكون السرير بارد يا
سهام ونادين ايضا بهذه المهنه يعني اشتهرت
صناعه الاقفاص الخاصه بالبلابل هنانا بس
اريد اسالك عمو ليش يعني
الاقفاص مال البلابل تختلف عن الاقفاص
الطيور الاخرى دائما تكون عباره عن اقفاص
من ساعه الخفر ماتت الشعب دائما الرغابه
اللي يجنون بلابل يعني يفضلون القفص مالت
السعه لانه مات الحديد والمعدن دائما يكون
بالصيف حار وبعدين املس في الحيوان الطير
ما يقدر يوقف عليه بسهوله ودائما منقاره
حلقه يتاذى
طبعا هذه المهنه يعني رغم من حسابها لكن
اليوم لابد ان نجد في كل زوايا من زوايا
البيوت العراقيه يعني اكو بعض الاثاث اللي
مصنوع من سعف النخيل كحفاظ على التراث
الشعبي وكذلك في المطاعم والاماكن
الترفيهيه يا سهام
يسعد صباحك على هالمعلومات دايما شكرا
جزيلا زينب نشاط من بغداد